billy porter i love there's a story
about you as a kind of a young child
actor i think was it a school production
yes so i was in the sixth grade
i was introduced to musical theater
risenstein middle school in pittsburgh
pennsylvania
changed my life i was the second banana
in the sixth grade i was the second
banana in the seventh grade so when the
eighth grade rolled around middle school
sixth seventh and eighth grade in
america
you know i thought okay
the musical is oliver clearly i'm going
to be the lead right yeah i've paid my
dues i'm going to be the lead i audition
the cast list goes up it says oliver
twist
eric pearson now
i had gone to the carnegie library i had
done my research i had learned where is
love i prepared for the audition i
marched right into the to the director's
office who was the instrumental teacher
mr lutz who i'm still friends with to
this day and i said why am i not playing
oliver
13. he's like well you're playing fagan
i said who's [ __ ]
said fagin's really the lead i was like
the show's called oliver
not
[ __ ] he said well go home and read the
script
and you'll understand what i mean
so i go home and read the script at 13
years old that means what counting your
lines
the [ __ ] doesn't even come on until
the end of that one he's in the last
thing the back one i'm like what are you
talking about i'm the lead this isn't
gonna work for me
he was like it's gonna be fine you're
gonna love it fast forward to
we're doing the performance of course i
played the part we're doing the
performance
and
i come out on stage in the last scene of
act one
two applause
was like
that's when i learned the meaning
of a star interest
ain't no going back from there
i'll wait till the last scene of that
one
it's funny right
beyond daphne
[Music]